babe right now today i got a live
chrissy chaos podcast in montreal then
tomorrow i am headlining club soda in
montreal friday july 29th and it is an
all-new hour of material if you've seen
me on the road in the last year this is
60 minutes of brand spanking new and
guess what bubbas if you go to
christiecomedy.com
right now not only do we have montreal
today montreal tomorrow we have the brea
improv in august then we have san
francisco in september and chicago in
september and we've added tarrytown okay
tarrytown in west texas terrytown we've
added we've been in milwaukee we've
added uh wiscon madison wisconsin um and
we've added minneapolis minnesota plus
more in the south christiecomedy.com i'm
so excited about my new hour material
it's wild
all right guys here's here's what we're
doing we're not going on the road again
until october but we've got tons of
cities and you have tons of time to get
good tickets right now uh october 14th
we're in hamilton ontario okay uh
toronto on october 15th toronto you've
been asking me i'm there then we're
going to richmond virginia we're going
to hershey pennsylvania we're going to
knoxville we're going to atlanta georgia
we're going to the alabama theater in
birmingham alabama we're going to
louisville kentucky we're going to
evansville indiana we are going to
florida by way of jacksonville tampa and
orlando and then of course in california
we have dates at sacramento santa rosa
and san jose everything is on sale right
now at
savilecanocomedy.com
you got a couple of months get some
friends together get some tickets come
have a good time
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey
believe it or not i'm
[Music]
who could it be
believe it or not it's hey babe
hello my favorite part of that is how
you guys make relentless eye contact
singing to each other good news guys
toxic masculinity's over
on the broadcast folks that's our guest
and i'm wearing a shirt that says
whitney and whitney's here in blackface
[Laughter]
can you not wear my blackface photo on
your shirt
like the fact that you had i'm feeling
pretty good about myself like my career
i show up you're wearing the more famous
whitney on your shoulder and you know
what's so fun
is that the only other big famous
whitney that we can name whitney
cummings port
whitney who port she was on like one of
those laguna beach shows not that i not
that i google whitney and then see who
comes up first constantly to see what is
it here walt whitney what women whitman
whitman yeah walt disney and whitman you
just remixed all women whitney i would
say
personally in my life i don't know
personally another whitney other than
you do you know what's second whitney i
don't think i do
it's a common name but you don't meet
that many whitneys why are you erasing
whitney houston that's erasure no no
because because i don't know whitney
houston personally oh okay i've i've
i've um
you've been to her grave do you come
across a lot of whitneys
have you i just did my special in newark
i kind of did my stand up on her great
special at new york that's crazy you've
been to that venue the uh new jersey
pack
amazing yeah
well i this is a joke that i ended up
cutting but i said um you know so many
comedians now are getting so much
publicity and fame off of getting
assaulted on stage that i wanted to
shoot my special in newark to make sure
i got assaulted
yeah
i cut that joke because i just was like
i didn't want to deal with people
playing ear punching down to new jersey
i'm like i shot here because i was
trying to like help the city you know
yeah that's where you shot in jersey to
help you have to help the city but i
this is actually why did you shoot this
this is actually weird whitney saves
newark
i say giraffes in cities
i don't like when people trash
cities as like a go-to punch line you
know what i mean like and newark is one
of those cities that i just feel like
everyone like shits on right and i like
the idea of shooting there and i cause i
was initially going to call it live from
newark that's funny
funny and then i was in montclair which
by the way i'm obsessed with montclair
yeah
theater out there too
yeah right that's right for sure all the
businesses are mafia money laundering it
doesn't matter that's what you want
though it's a cute little thing like a
main street
that sells just vinegar as a woman the
safest place
is a neighborhood ran by the mafia you
want the mafia back
nobody's messing with women if the mafia
runs the city and that's why rudy julian
well the mafia will mess with you but
nobody else no but the mafia will only
mess with you if you mess with them and
if they see any type of discretion or
action towards a woman
the mafia will intervene but won't the
question is do i present as a woman
that's
very interesting that you say that
because as soon
as you walked in i said whitney's trans
whatever i need to do to get chappelle
to talk about me
but so i was there and then i wanted to
shoot at the welmont theater and i
couldn't because i was already
performing there and then i went and saw
that one okay and it made sense but
actually weirdly total 360 180 however
whatever number works for this i watched
the documentary on whitney houston which
is fantastic did you is the recent one
that she's a lesbian her aunt was a
child molester you don't see too many
females drop i didn't hear about this i
watch it on a plane me too yes i don't
think it came out anywhere but a plane
because it was like
awkwardly revealing
it's nuts she's a lesbian dion warwick's
sister
sister was molesting whitney houston as
a child and made her into a undercover
lesbo
and she
[Laughter]
was so great
the word lesbian comes from lesbos
greece so lesbos is a city in greece is
that true yeah of course you don't have
chrissy histories yeah so you're saying
lesbians are greasy lesbians are greasy
yeah fair yeah yeah lesbians smell like
feta cheese that's what i'm saying
my dad's mom used to be like the mayor
of her little neighborhood and she used
to have the dirt on everybody and like
people would walk down she and say hello
and then she'd always lean to be like
sweet girl les les sweet girl though
so so whitney houston yeah okay
literally is this woman alive that
molester dion warwick's sister i believe
is i don't know if she's what did dion
warmer say about me do you know warwick
was not a doc
they were related it was her
it was dion warwick's sister it was
winning houston's aunt
it was whitney houston's there's got to
be a shorter way to say that
was whitney using his father
right he was a woman yeah right i know
but we don't
see sal doesn't see gender he's
progressive i don't see gender or
anything the point is i watched it and
it made me think about like new work
she's from newark i don't know if i
totally put that together and then the
person she i guess had an affair with
the entire uh time of her fame wait what
made the documentary it was hers right
so it was all this footage of them
when she had a secret relationship
outside of mr brown she was an
undercover lesbian dude you have got to
fly delta yeah that is where this is
starting with this jet blue ship dude it
is worth taking a flight just round trip
just to watch this no it literally it
literally was
blowing my mind
watching this documentary i verified
that she did this this was what she said
it was her stuff
wow it was her women do lie about that a
lot
but no it was her stylist or something
her best friend from high school or
something childhood and then i think the
crazier part is there was all this
footage of her from concerts no one's
ever seen before where she was like
tweaked out on drugs yeah it was really
it was sad
to watch the power how powerful whitney
houston's voice was in the late 80s
early 90s actually like it's like um
like it makes you like emotional yeah
how good of a sin like how unbelievable
let's see you put her above
uh
mariah 100 yes about mariah yeah she
mariah's not even [ __ ] mariah no listen
mariah baby pacifier i love you
yeah she just she can genuinely
she she okay she's the best she's like
the
michael jordan of singing mary j blige
i'm just pulling this yes but not in a
different it does something different
marriage queen
okay in terms of pipes alone
what's the lady who's like kidding
french canadian adele oh no celine
what about her she's got pipes different
registers
[Music]
here's the thing whitney houston a lot
of them can hit the same notes as
whitney houston but that [ __ ] just
didn't stop it didn't always saying here
that she is bar none the best female
vocalist no the best female vocalist and
performer is actually not everyone in
houston it's her hologram in vegas
have you seen this thing yes it is the
most disrespectful [ __ ] i have ever seen
what is that hologram this is in vegas
it's a vegas live show where you go and
watch her
and it is the creepiest [ __ ] i've ever
laid my eyes on it's on youtube i saw
the michael jackson hologram and it was
have you ever seen a hologram not in
front of your face no it's really
actually mind-blowingly freaky no that's
gonna
hologram already already there's
this he has a company howie mandel has
this company that they have a booth and
then they put holograms like you can
hologram like you can do a conference
from like la and hong kong and literally
be there no i think he's such a
germaphobic he's like someone in the
next room yeah yeah he has to do it yeah
he's someone in the next room from his
hologram and you literally can react in
real time like you are there yeah and so
that's gonna be like what's gonna happen
here's the way she's oh my god dude it's
wild she can watch a whole and there she
does a whole show but may i something i
don't think the technology's there yet
it's still gl like she's still moving
very well let's say we didn't let's say
we didn't know about the technology and
we looked at this right this second the
people in front of her are real people
but she's not
look at it oh she's in different look at
her head look at her head yeah it still
looks weird
and it's not moving from that box i
think that the body is a real person
it's just that this is what i'm asking
is this footage taken from her at a real
concert and then they just made it into
a hologram or is this someone making not
her body with her body photoshopped on
the ladder really dark dark times wow so
they really got to get her frame and her
body like her game coming
you got to find her like what her gate
is like did you know the anthony you
know the anthony bourdain documentary
road runner yes like you know the last
20 minutes of that or not the last 20
minutes the entire documentary of that
voiceover he was dead already they
artificially intelligence his voice and
it you think that it's anthony bourdain
it is not so what's going to start to
happen is is the scandals the crimes all
that is going to be used for negative
like so soon yeah yeah you will be put
in a situation you were not in and you
can't prove that you have to defend
yourself against a better alibi bye bye
yeah but then you're ba
baby yeah
um oh gosh i had to
bump them up i only now do that on other
people's podcasts to watch to see if
they could not roll their eyes i still
wear whitney cummings merch
you can have great merch it's pretty
good all my friends kids love it my my
daughter religiously wears that
black and white shirt all the time she
loves she goes
all the time
baby delilah um but also what am i
saying
we're talking about um um cg uh
you're gonna be fine so about this
there's never gonna be because when i
did the special the last one where i'd
like the robot in it i went deep into
this [ __ ] so oh yeah you got that you
had a that was freaky i'm bad with money
yeah wow
they told me to cut things for my
special i'm like i wish they had told me
to [ __ ] cut that 200 thousand dollars
[ __ ] wasn't that much wonder it ended
up being yeah the robot for my last
special ended up being like yeah maybe
200 grand at the end of the day where
does that live her head is in my podcast
studio her body got sawed in half in a
foo fighters movie
oh that's 666 thing yes okay but um
about that so if there is someone that's
gonna deep fake you or photoshop you in
or use your voice you are going to be
able to look at the metadata to see that
it's been changed okay so until there's
a way to obfuscate metadata you're going
to be fine okay like you know what i
mean like actually it might
help yeah i also i've gotten to the
point now in my life where i don't care
i know the government has a scan of my
face i know they have my dna from
23andme i i genuinely don't same i've
got i know they have it but well i kind
of just want to get in my eyes every
time i get on a plane we used to have a
book full of everyone's phone numbers
and home addresses and we just threw it
at your house like it's wild to me like
yeah i have a friend he has an alexa in
his house won't even talk around it he
won't talk about his alexa because he
thinks he's being held captive by a
machine like he bought you have anyone
that has an alexa
i have one right there but it's
unplugged because i got freaked out by
it but then don't you she'll know you
unplugged her
she will yes she no sometimes she would
just start talking for real and i i mean
we were doing a podcast sometimes you
just started talking i just don't know
why because people are so worried
they're like well what you say is going
to affect like your health insurance and
like if they say like do you want a
cigarette well that's what the paranoia
is that if you and i are hanging out and
i'm like oh can i have a cigarette or
you're like can i get that cigarette
it's going oh he smokes and it's good i
just think we need to like throw him off
you just have to say [ __ ] you don't mean
every now and then yeah like just say
like what's the how do we donate to
saint jude's children's hospital again
like you
[Laughter]
[Music]
and yeah but that's going to get
reported to who they can't come in the
insurance companies like well we heard
alexis say that you said that i don't
know they can do all that [ __ ]
everything you google they're saying now
that if you uh when older people use
their mouse or their uh keypad that if
they start they're like shaky they can
tell that you have early onset
alzheimer's and your insurance company
like knows before you even know i'm
gonna i this or they can tell if you
drink at night because that night you'll
be drunk and
like i i had to get for my life
insurance i had to get life insurance
you know kids whatever and i had to get
um like a a medical person comes over
and there's your blood pressure your
blood a medical person a medical medical
personnel how long do you go to school
for that to become a medical person yeah
i think you've got to do three years at
community college
you got to do an extra year for yourself
they show up with each other
it says medical person you're like
yeah
so so this medical person they say um
they're doing the test to me doing the
test blood pressure blood pressure is
always a little high and he goes have
you been drinking and i said um
uh no he goes no just tell me like if
you've been drinking because like i
could smell alcohol on your breath i was
like yeah you know like i i work late
wait i swear to god you went to get your
checkup no the medical person comes to
your house they have to come to your
house and life insurance okay just
because they do you were drinking prior
no i was drinking the night before and
you still smell like alcohol
no but it was like they come at like
seven a.m okay so how do you want to
phrase it frame it it's okay i had to
because there's like tier one which is
like you know fully covered and then
there's like two three like the more
unhealthy you get why did you get
shit-faced the night before your life
insurance i forgot medical personal
exams i genuinely forgot i had it they
woke they rang the bell at 7 a.m and we
were like who the [ __ ] is that and then
i was like [ __ ] uh and then i was like
oh [ __ ] i forgot about this yeah so he
goes have you been drinking and i said
yeah like a little that i was like okay
because your blood pressure's high and i
was like okay and then they literally
came back a week later and gave me tier
two health insurance so i have to pay a
higher premium because they were like he
drinks he's he's drinks like he's he's
an avid drinker it's like it's it's
you wanted this sir you knew we were
coming you decided to do this yeah like
you put us in a corner dude i think if i
die if i die my kids will get like two
mil you could have not bad that's not
bad that's not bad it's almost like
enough to is it's not enough to kill you
though it's just nice it's not enough
not in this game but let me ask you a
question it doesn't involve jasmine
wouldn't get the money until each child
turned eighteen so there's nothing
yeah just wait for it yeah yeah
you're not inviting any skills violet is
one so it's like you're going to kill me
and then wait 17 years yeah you're going
to do how long are you going to have 2
million and 17 years
yeah can a will change that like do you
also if you have life insurance you also
do a will i did a will too do
so if i die tomorrow which is likely
okay i
i everything in my life that's left in
the will goes into a trust that is
controlled by a lawyer and my oldest
daughter will get it when she's 18 and
then she becomes the beneficiary and
then she becomes the person that can
designate to her little and then she'll
be the executor of the estate exactly
but if you say i don't want any of my
daughters to have any money for example
not that you would but can you put that
in the will to override the life
insurance i could do whatever i want
okay no no no no no you can't override
the life and the life insurance is going
to pay out whoever it's going to pay out
i think you can't just take like a cash
prize and just to give it to anybody oh
i see you're saying yeah no no no the
life insurance that i'm paying to
william penn shout out um i if i that
money will automatically has to go to my
child right my oldest daughter but you
only put everything in your oldest
daughter's name and then you're going to
trust like she and then she delegates
i did this whole thing when i did my
will it was it was excruciating
like 30 people and break it down to
percentages
i'm fascinated by that i kind of want to
leave a lot of money to like
an x that i haven't seen
just randomly for like 15 years yeah
yeah just trevor got it all and you're
like what dude literally he got 30
million i didn't know he's like there's
two broke
[Laughter]
working at a gas station in timonium
maryland you know what else i want to do
the people that i know like talk [ __ ]
about me and don't like me leave money i
want so they would feel so
mindful
the idea that like like i'll just like
like kevin brennan's gonna be like
whitney left me five million dollars
[ __ ]
why was i such a dick
i'm leaving everything to putin
everything leave it on
it'll find its way over there
literally
the will the whale life insurance thing
though it's like morbid like to think
about like what this is what's going to
happen
do you do y'all fly on separate
aircrafts as your partner
no no i never have done that that's the
most sinister show yeah you i always
think about this you i can't believe it
and i don't i mean but how did a
professional sports team not take get
taken out in full i don't i think about
that i might think about that
i think about that i would be so
freaking nervous if i was on like how do
they not fly them all like half the team
should fly in one plane and then unless
they're a team they live as a team
yeah
do you see yellow jackets
i oh is that i started so why is that
with the people on the island yes it's
about a soccer team from the 90s like
this all-state soccer team it is girls
it's like lord of the flies yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they crashed on an
island and just start [ __ ] pimpy
killing it google google aloha airlines
hawaii 1988 roof rip-off
like disaster show lost no no no it's
like it's like on uh on like um maybe
the history channel comedians instagram
yeah
literally let me wanna look at the
[ __ ] plan
there did people fly out of it oh no
no
look cb lansing was sucked out over the
pacific ocean
oh my god no no
they're drop they're flying this plane
aloha airlines and here's what i didn't
know so when you fly look at this look
at this the roof ripped off in the
middle of the pacific ocean it ripped
off when was this out of 1988 so many
things have went into the faa now to
like you know stop this from happening
but i was watching it when you fly when
you go up and down on those planes you
the
i didn't know it's like planes like
breathe like they expanded
yeah that's coming the wings could like
go like that yes yeah so aft this plane
was supposed to do like 20 000 trips it
was out like 50 000 trips because nobody
checks this yeah so the roof just ripped
off it got like a wind gust and one of
the flight attendants was like serving
drinks and he fully got sucked out into
the ocean and then all other than him
every other single person survived they
if you if you had your seatbelt on you
survived if you did not have your
seatbelt down you died somebody said was
holding their wife by her ankles and
then the people were pulling her down
like she was mary poppins and then
strapped her in and she [ __ ] survived
oh my god
soon after number one and number two it
does look like it is just the first
class kathy yeah
super [ __ ] up i never wear my seat
belt i never do i'm gonna never i'm
never not gonna wear it literally the
the roof ripped off the pilot somehow
landed the plane so the pilots could not
communicate by the way with air traffic
control because whatever the sensor was
controlled ripped off on the road
so they just had to
one of the guys one of the guys who
works at the honolulu airport saw this
plane coming landing with no roof and
was like clear the [ __ ] runway wow
they didn't even know if their nose gear
was down because the buttons didn't work
so they just had to hope and pray that
when they pressed the button and the
nose gear came down so they could land
because they were like either we're
gonna blow up yeah on the runway or
we're gonna land like normal i would've
died of a heart attack before you know
what's interesting i i often think when
i think about these horrific things when
people crash i'm like what was it like
that five minutes before i can't even
think about it like those people know
what it's like
it's not funny at all because they were
about to die right what did people think
they were they they hadn't experience
that we would we will never want to have
to see this one hawaiian woman who got
off the plane i it was thank god she's
but her hair was blown out
here because they were going 30 000.
[Music]
[Laughter]
off a flight where you were just had a
brush with death and it's like yeah i
would rather be on tv than processing
yeah no are you sure it wasn't just
because it was 88 and that was a style
i don't know her hair was as blown out
as it could possibly be
no she literally looked like you know
like when a male turkey puts like their
like the halo thing up that's what they
look like okay that happens to one of us
right
our careers we have to travel for our
career you have to you're on that flight
do you ever fly again are you like it
can't happen twice i'm gonna do it
that's when you're the safest almost but
that's not real right it's not real but
it is like when something bad happens
there is like this damocles sword has
found like what are the chances this
would happen again i think i'm bus after
that only never do it again no i don't
know a psychologist would tell you you
have to do it again the only way to get
over it is you must do it again they
want less clients they want less spots
yeah yeah
no i i
i can ask a question what are the plane
crashes we have had in our lifetime like
remember the one than the everglades
holy [ __ ] everglades like that was in
our lifetime
oh that was a big one
there's been a lot there's been a lot
but it's mostly private planes that
crash private planes are really sketchy
i mean they're owned by peop they're
owned by people like jeffrey epstein
whose priority isn't like
updating the jet and you know what i
mean
you're basically like and also the
pilots are kind of star [ __ ] like i
feel like that's what happened with with
kobe is kobe the basically he
compromised the lafd like was grounded
like like police force was grounded they
weren't even flying and then the guy was
like we shouldn't fly and kobe was like
that's fine and then you're like that's
your boss
right that's your private guy and you're
like oh [ __ ] it i'm with kobe i must be
invincible so i i i think i don't know
if i told this story so my friend who
i've had close calls you had close calls
i feel like they were close called maybe
they weren't but well have you ever been
on a flight for real where you saw the
flight attendants nervous have you ever
tried because that's the only way to
know one commercial i feel like they all
want to die one commercial these days
one commercial uh they didn't even
collect the they didn't come back and
collect the food food was flying
everywhere on my way home from greece
just slamming again wait a minute like
they didn't even get tray tables up none
of that no they just sat down and you
just saw them like buckled in just like
breathing like the rest of us and the
tray tables was there turbulence was
turbulence crazy it was the worst that
it felt like though someone was hitting
the plane with like a like a bat the
size of the plane like it was just like
boom like it felt like the plane hit the
ground but we were in the air was it
summers like like it was july it was
july 2000 so we're flying through a a
like a thunderstorm i guess i was home
coming home from greece i don't know i
don't know what the hell happened
whatever it is i knew you went to greece
a couple times uh on the once in a blue
when we had to like when we take the
smaller planes and stuff like that
that is the worst because that just just
wind and the thing is like it says just
sliding like that and there's no you
looking out the front window so like one
time we were gonna go landing there's
two pilots up there and we're you know
it's almost like that you know when you
drop on like a roller coaster yeah it's
doing that thing and we're like oh my
god to the point where i wrote we all
wrote texts to our families we actually
got a bit out of it but we all wrote
text to our families and we were holding
on on like to hitting send yeah as we
were coming down because what was the
message i have one i i saved it because
i used to remember
i told them to my family that i said why
not because the wheel wasn't coming down
and they told you that they told us hey
is there is that a law that they have to
tell you because i'm like i didn't need
to know that
i i mean they gotta i mean there must be
a law so so we go to land right we go to
land we're on this little plane and it's
bad out already and it's shaking and you
see like the you see through the window
and everything and he goes and then we
go and he pulls back up so he pulls back
up we're like what the [ __ ] was that he
got i thought you were landing we were
going to land right we were like
50 feet from the ground he pulls back up
guy comes back he goes hey
he goes so does he look nervous and feel
nervous he
he didn't look like try frightened but
he was like talking to us sternly and he
goes okay so we have a small issue
one of the wheels is not coming down
well he goes our instruments are saying
it's not coming down but we don't know
if the instruments are wrong or it's not
coming down this is with aloha aloha
aloha flight same [ __ ] really you never
really know if it's the instruments or
the wheel you the pilots can't see so
i'm like why not have a clear bottom
floor for the pilots well that's what he
said so he goes but he's got to wait to
you have to make it you have to have a
guy with good eyes that's what he does
so we go we go back around we go flying
all the way around he goes in a big big
[ __ ] circle comes back what what are
you saying i said you can't have stevie
wonder out there you gotta have a guy
here
no machine stuff a guy in a lot of
carrots all day just looking for the
wheel coming down
[Laughter]
we have a monocle we fly back around he
says this time we told control so
they're going to look and they're going
to let us know if it's down or not we go
to land we're going down down down they
pull back up they go air traffic control
cannot tell can you believe that so this
is two botched lanterns two two botched
landings jesus goes back up it's a small
plane goes back up he goes all right
um
he goes here's the deal he goes we don't
have enough fuel to get to another
airport
or to stall and like that much longer
how could the first airport not see the
how do you know
oh i couldn't believe that he said that
they couldn't tell but they couldn't
tell so the third time he goes we don't
have enough fuel to get anywhere else so
we're going to land we're going to loop
around and land now no matter what we
have to can't planes land without wheels
it's shitty but yeah they're designed
for that so what he says is he goes
don't he dead this with a [ __ ]
straight face he goes don't worry he
said if the wheel
the wheel doesn't come down the wing
will act like a wheel
that's that's what he said
oh he just looked at him like what wait
act like
[Laughter]
for the third time we went to go land i
was full i'm not ashamed to say it i was
full crying because i asked you what was
going on in your body yeah were you i i
were you like your stomach dropped
dropped you were crying crying shaking
shaking were the other guys crying um
everyone was trying to hold it together
for each other q was trying to hold it
together for me murray was visibly
shaken and then joe the lunatic that he
is
he he just had a shirt
singing
you know they all died in the crash
he's trying to get me to laugh and i'm
crying he's singing the bomb i'm like
i'm still crying he goes he goes let me
go were you on the plane too no no okay
no nobody it was just us he goes let me
let me see if i can get service because
we had service because it was low so we
had services we all started writing off
families and we were holding i wrote off
i was feverishly writing i could find it
in here i could find it it's like the
plane the wheel's not coming down i
don't know how it's going to happen i
don't really know what i love you all so
much i'm you know i i was telling them
who i'm leaving
you think you're gonna die you're like a
child you live in
don't be ohio when you see the will
to a bunch of kids in orlando
and then i land and then i just a text
comes right into this jk jk jk jk
wait so you're fully like no dude i'm
not i was crying like i couldn't even
control the crying i couldn't not cry
and then joe goes let me call my wife
and he goes
hello
because the big bopper was on the plane
that died
he goes willa what and he starts doing
like the big bopper to his wife yeah and
i'm just like you're a lunatic and i
kind of am laughing that kind of helped
you a little bit not really yeah i was
laughing and crying at the same time and
then dude we came down came down and
were like i'm watching out the window
because i don't know if it's going to
hit and then we're going to it's going
to go like that and the wings are going
to fly but we're going to spin how long
he's going to get ripped open a fire
anything but how long were you thinking
you were going to die until
uh it was a matter of like 5-10 minutes
and as you were landing this has
happened to me before did you see a
bunch of fire trucks i was just about to
say loaded the runway that's when you're
[ __ ] did they load the runway we
loaded the runway we saw ambulances fire
trucks all the time
all the things explode yeah
yeah and then and then we touched down
and
the wheel was down so it was it was a
normal landing yeah normal yeah yeah so
do they still take you in a stretcher
they're like this one
well the guy
the guy the guy the first guy to open
the hatch was wearing like one of those
like e.t space suits yeah like this yeah
just like fire replacement
he looked like a [ __ ] ass shot and he
opened it and he went oh man guy got a
picture with you guys i'm a huge fan did
you take a picture
and it's so funny because he's smiling
and the three guys are smiling and in
the picture i'm [ __ ] furious i
couldn't even smile like you answer a
picture did you have the show that night
or were you landing back home uh we were
coming home from a show wow yeah yeah no
no no no no no no no we were not we
didn't land here it happened somewhere
else so we were landing
in another town for a show do you even
remember what town it was i think it was
i think it was minnesota but i'm not
positive oh my gosh yeah it was
horrifying now a word from our sponsor
better better help
um
you got to take care of your mind we're
going going going our minds are racing
some mile a minute a mile a minute
things are piling up
it's important to stop down take a
little break take a health break yeah
and uh a mental health
you want to take health breakthrough you
want to have a bar or something like
that you take care of something nice you
take care of things like your car why
not take care of your brain yeah take
what yeah because listen babe
the last couple of years have been crazy
and now you know greenland's melting
there's a whole bunch of things we're
going to talk about greenland melting
sure there's a whole bunch of things
going on where we all need to talk to
someone or at least i feel that sal
feels that we use better help and it
helps us and if something's helping us
we want to give it to you to help you
babe because we care about you because
we love you okay and if you if you've
been living under a rock or you haven't
watched a podcast until today better
help is basically online therapy uh that
offers video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions you don't even
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't want to yeah it's cheaper and more
affordable than in-person therapy you
could be matched with a therapist within
under 48 hours yeah my therapist i've
been talking to my therapist now for two
months on better help i've never once
turned on the camera and neither have
they they could be butt naked i have no
idea imagine you both are that's also a
fun thing that's a fun intangible they
don't even talk about yeah that it might
be just be fun when you're talking that
you're both naked you don't even know
we're both bucky naked yeah our
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com hey babe uh that's
betterhelp.com
hey babe if you ever was thinking about
therapy whatsoever and you were
intimidated by going in person or
actually finding a therapist this is the
perfect way to introduce yourself to it
and uh yeah
try it out better help speaking of the
sun coming out you know what you need
shady rays that's what it is it's also
the name of my uh girlfriend's
ex-boyfriend
um
i actually got my two pairs of shady
rays in the mail like three days ago
shady rays actually
are an insanely amazing product i have
three pairs of them i got one for me i
got one for the baby and i got one for
my dad i love a baby in sunglasses how
funny is a baby in sunglasses it's the
best i know if you don't love people
once you have one of those annoying
babies well then they keep taking them
off or like you put a hat on a baby and
that baby takes the hat off it's like
come on baby are we playing games here
or not you you were cute five minutes
ago but it's like you you know what
you're
yeah it's enough with it what i like
about shady raids as a company is not
only do they have amazing eyewear and
they look cool and they have br you know
you can get the you can get them
replaced very easily but what i love
about them as a company is they provide
10 meals to fight hunger in america with
every order and have donated over 20
million meals to date look good in your
shades and feel good by making it 100 uh
pim just go right back to where you are
they're an independent sunglass company
that offers world-class product that's
just as good as the expensive pairs you
wear but they're adorable frames they're
extremely clear polarized lenses for
outdoor adventures but they are just
more affordable shady raise offers the
most insane protection of any eye we're
out there i dare you to come up and tell
me an eyewear company that has better
protection every pair is backed by their
lost and broken replacements no more
losing you know we're preparing a cab
sitting on a on a pair with fat ass and
crushing them you get those replacement
questions asked right now if you go to
shadyraise.com and use the code hey babe
you're going to get 50 off right and
another thing
is 50 off uh two or more pairs that's
what i meant to say yes that's so just
to clarify exclusively for our listeners
yes shady raises giving out their best
deal of the season yep go to
shadyrates.com and use the code hey babe
50 off two or more pairs of polarized
sunglasses try for yourself the shades
are rated five stars by over two hundred
thousand people
two hundred thousand people i love it
man everything every the world's about
being polarized these days shady ray's
got the polarized sunglasses
i think at least three times a week
about the guy that intentionally crashed
that plane oh with the german guy into
the mountains and just went right into a
[ __ ] on purpose that german guy yeah and
then what about the guy from the
malaysia airlines that purposely went up
to 60 000 feet knocked all the
passengers unconscious and then it just
nose dived into the middle of the
pacific ocean oh that's wait he knew he
was going down they so so two it's the
one german guy crashed he was suicidal
so he crashed the plane into a mountain
and there was no co-pilot
i don't know
but the malaysian guy oh so he just
himself
yeah suicidal yeah you know what
i don't think he was actually i think he
stole the plane didn't he steal the
plane well the german guy that i
remember i think was like the licensed
pilot and just that because the debate
because two things happened after 9 11
they security bolted the door you cannot
get into that door it doesn't matter
what kind of tools you have and that
created a conundrum that was post 911
you could go in there before that that's
how they got it they opened the door and
they remember when you used to walk on
the plane and like hey do you want to
see the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you were like cute and you
had a good body they would just like
invite you
yeah you could just sit on the controls
there was also a malaysia one where
because of the culture in asia you don't
disagree with one of your authority
figures
the guy the pilot was screwing up but
the younger co-pilot felt like he
couldn't that was the korean
elder yeah that was in korea so the
dynamic in korea is you cannot speak to
your elder and correct them on anything
that including the korean community do
you mean you're superior in the
workforce so say you're the pilot i'm
the co-pilot i know you're flying into a
mountain this is exactly what happened
on korean air
line this was like in the earth that
makes no logical korean if i'm the
co-pilot i know what the i know that's
tradition but it's not gonna matter the
tradition when i crashed it
disagree with this guy and then he's
like i'll die nobly yeah yeah i'll let
everyone die on this plane and crash
because i don't want to disrespect well
i told you when i was watching the world
war ii documentary you know with pearl
harbor one of the pla uh uh you know
comic on
japanese air force they they gave the
wrong intel they thought in the japanese
attack pearl harbor because they thought
the entirety of the u.s pacific fleet
was going to be in pearl harbor and they
had a guy deciphering american messages
for weeks like espionage and the
japanese guy whose english like really
wasn't that good instead of seeing he
saw december 6th but it was really like
december 8th so they attacked pearl
harbor on december six but half the
invasion fleet wasn't the seventh
december 7th sorry but half the or they
they left japan on this exactly so so so
that the invasion fleet the i'm sorry
the u.s carriers were all in the middle
of the ocean they did not he done [ __ ]
up that [ __ ] up yeah so he gets back
and he's like i messed up whatever it's
like you know whatever and then they
said okay immediately go outside and we
will behead you just immediately you you
got beheaded immediately no no
immediately and he willingly did it he
the guy was like you know he was like
he was like i'm at what time behead me
now like cut my [ __ ] head off that's
how it is in japan in japan if you [ __ ]
up at all in the military they like
stick a knife a dagger through your
heart you [ __ ] and they can't wait to
they love to do it a lot of times
they'll get ahead of it not anymore to
commit suicide before they can even
right right isn't it but not anymore
right not anymore they have to put nets
because with japan they identify you
identify so much with your career in
japanese customs that when you retire
your senior citizens kill themselves
left and right in japan because they a
whole identity is oh i worked for apple
and then your job at apple is over like
oh retirement package and then you're
sitting at home for two weeks you're
like i can't [ __ ] do this i'm not
gonna talk to my wife kill me wow pimp's
got something to say did you see the
baggage handler who stole a plane and
crashed it he stole a plane and crashed
was this recently it was from 2018 but
the security camera footage like an
actual commercial airline someone walked
into a plane that wasn't even a pilot
did he kill everybody on board he had
played video games so he actually was
kind of good at it that's what he said
yeah so wait so he landed the plane like
nobody died he's the baggage guy he
played video games so he actually was
able to do it mostly yeah he was on he's
on the phone with air traffic control
and they're like what are you doing so
we just did it for fun he just did it
wait but he was the only one on it yeah
he just stole the plane
landed it oh was alaska it was uh that
guy with the face on it
yeah but what game is that accurate
i don't know grand theft auto i don't
know and this is a picture of the crash
this is the guy stealing the plane yeah
did he does he get airborne with this
thing he just took off yes
is there like a police plane to go after
him how does he yeah what do you do now
just crash it into an island he died oh
he died yeah
wow fully hijacked a plane in 2018. but
he did this like he wanted to commit
suicide this way
i don't know if he thought that far
ahead you think he was like oh [ __ ] what
am i supposed to do now
well that's like the jeff blue worker
that who was a baggage handler who was a
narcoleptic and was loading bags
on on a flight from new york to boston
is loading the bags under the the plane
and then falls asleep like that and then
wakes up and comes out of the plane and
doesn't understand his surroundings he
flew to boston in the hall of the
aircraft and that flight only goes 10
000 feet so he survived if it would have
went from new york to anywhere else
atlanta he would have died from
pressurized pressurized but that one
only goes ten thousand because such a
short flight and then he woke up and
they opened up the hole and they had
guns on it because they were like
there's a
like they didn't know what the hell this
guy was doing and then he sued jetblue
for like 10 million dollars and won he
won he's won
this job is so boring i can't stay awake
yeah this is your fault no he won the
lawsuit yeah my friend lil dibo knew him
i think or knew the story yeah did you
ever did you ever see a narcoleptic up
for impersonal upfront have you seen
someone i i worked with a guy who was
narcoleptic still work with him to this
day in 20 22 years ago so so what so
what would happen i would go what was
his job it was he we worked in the wrong
nightmare for a comedian
we worked in prudential securities i
used to go up to his floor to get like
uh i used to go get stuff from him and
if i got up his name was charles if i
got up there and he was sleeping the the
instruction was do not wake him because
if you do wake him like
it's like not healthy like it's it could
be it could be damaging but do you when
you apply for a job do you have to tell
them if you're narcoleptic
i don't know
i feel like this guy just slept he it
was like a 50 50 shot if he was sleeping
and they couldn't get rid of him and i
would go i would hope that i would need
to work and i would just walk through
this he was sitting there
there is no way he gave them a heads up
like just fyi he was older he was like
an older girl actually i don't believe
him actually i think that he
i think that he's like i'll just say i'm
a narcoleptic so i can work half the day
anytime he started super unfortunately
he was like he's like oh [ __ ]
it is it is a real thing i guess
animals i've seen animals that just
clock out like it's like not a gradual
sleep did you ever see him when he just
like fell asleep was it slow
i saw him
trying to remember because it was 20
something years ago but i would stay a
little longer and stare at him right i
would i would i would hover around his
desk and just kind of stare at a little
bit when you watch someone sleeping you
like kind of fall in love with them yeah
that's what happened with me and him oh
yeah yeah that's called rape
[Laughter]
cosby
have you ever woken up and somebody was
watching you sleep yeah i i there do you
ever be around a person with full
tourette's like a real person with
tourette's there was a kid in my high
school had tourette's we were like 14 15
years old and i'm in high school and you
know a 14 year old kid it was funny we
didn't mean to laugh when she was 14 and
yeah because the first two weeks of
school you don't understand he has
tourette's and then we were all spoken
together but it was like but he would go
like we'd be like in biology class and
he'd like raise his hand like hey mr
demarco you know like he'd be asking a
question about biology like oh what's
like the anatomy of a frog and then you
go [ __ ] pool
and then you'd be like why [ __ ] what
[ __ ] pool he would say his turret
thing would go and he'd stick his tongue
and he'd go you [ __ ] pool pool call
people pool p-o-o-l i don't know what i
don't know he couldn't stop it and then
for four years he would go you [ __ ]
pool like that
nieces school they had to uh
take a kid out of school because he just
said the n-word over and over again
that's that's you get dealt a bed
tourette's hand there if the word is
damaged
it's the thing you're not supposed to
say
yeah that's why he was saying it yeah
yeah and it was just like constant like
a little remix yeah
they just move him to a school like in
charlottesville
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
well you know what i feel like i don't
hear about anymore mono
i have no i had friends in high school
that was all the rage back then the
epstein's
bar yeah come to school for years yeah
mono is that still a thing in school i
don't know that people talk about mono
anymore but when i had mono it was the
sickest i ever was in my life still to
this day i had it in eighth grade and it
was brutal and you just get chastised
like i remember my mother was like who
are you making out with and i was like
that's the only way to get it no i i my
my called the kids because they called
them kids but my doctor was like i was
like mom like no like i'm molested yeah
whitney houston's aunt
no i was i was trying it was like almost
embarrassing because i like hadn't even
kissed a girl yet and i was like i'm not
i haven't kissed anyone like i was like
oh you were sled shoes i was like i'm
like a [ __ ] like i've done like it was
really embarrassing i was like i've
never kissed anyone
everybody my dad was like who'd you kiss
who was it like she got hot mom like you
know and i was like no i'm literally
like it was like it's like the eighth
graders like bottles i was sharing
bottles people were scared as hell yeah
yeah dude i remember it was so bad i was
um uh at one point just spitting up
blood as 13 years old did we mask kids
for covid we didn't back that no i mean
kids were asleep for truly my best
friend in high school jen charlborg she
was asleep for two years yeah she didn't
come to school she had to have her
homework sent to her yeah because it was
she was that drained physically drained
i thought it was like a 30-day thing
it's like you could just stay with me
for months oh i heard you never recover
once you get epstein-barr from it you
you always have it epstein-barr by me
having epstein-barr i was told what's
that one epstein-barr is the thing that
causes mono got it and they say people
it is literally your life is different
yeah
and so did roseanne yeah so
so and bill started klondike yes
prior i mean i will say prior to jeffrey
though that's a fun name for a thing
it's better than chronic fatigue it's
like people love saying it you notice
that people love saying epstein bond
yeah okay listen it can be hard to see
the line at the end of the tunnel when
you have high interest debt and
sometimes it can be even harder to ask
for help that's where upstart comes in
folks saying goodbye to high interest
credit card debt is one of the first
steps toward financial independence but
the interests month after month can feel
like you're in a never-ending hamster
wheel that's where upstart comes in
we've already hate teams yeah we've all
been there seemingly out of nowhere you
get with an unexpected expense or a bill
and when that happens it can feel like
the weight of the world is on you
because you weren't expecting it and you
didn't budget for it and it's it's it's
normal to not know where to turn luckily
upstart is here to help yes upsharp
powered personal loans can help you pay
down high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom upstart knows you're
more than just your credit score so
rather than looking at your credit score
alone upstart's model considers other
factors like your income employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate
within minutes for loans between 1 000
to 50 000 bands that's 50 000
without impacting your credit score
don't wait check your rate today at
upstart.com hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you so they got it you got to
put slash a babe
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information providing your loan
application go to upstart.com
i said it before and i'll say it again
summer is in full swing and the
celebration begins during the summer of
dash pass by doordash
weekly member only offers and new items
released every week you can shine bright
and feel cool all season long babe
ordering your summer essentials with the
dash pass by doordash is a great way to
get everything you need during the
summer of dash pass you can save money
and access members only offers that will
help you feel easy and breezy and
beautiful cover girl and all season long
i love doordash because like the other
night i needed milk for my baby and i
just doored there because it's not just
restaurants it's not how about that it's
not and i'm telling you you can shine
bright throwing door dash your summer of
dash pass and you're going to get 50 off
your first order up to 15 value if you
just use the promo code hey babe at
check out when you spend 12 or more
that's 50
off your first order up to a 15 value
when you sign up for doordash during
summer of dash pass using promo code hey
babe don't forget that's code hey babe
for 50 off your first order up to 15
dollar value dash pass benefits only on
eligible orders that meet the minimum
subtotal terms apply yeah i've seen i
got the epstein bar and they they
thought duo you didn't know you needed
it yeah
initially the initial coveted
researchers thought that if you had
epstein-barr you're protected from
covenant i made it two and a half years
it might have had a little epstein-barr
yeah i made it to a few and then i got
it i got it
two weeks ago but i'm fine now
yeah symptoms uh
i couldn't i i got sick for one day and
then i couldn't taste and smell for
three days and i genuinely i'm being 100
percent honest with you i could and
that's 100
i was eating ass i was going crazy if i
if if that taste and smell
laugh absence lasted like a year i would
genuinely consider suicide
i was like i don't want to live like
this i don't want to live you are
depressed every second of the day
because you know you're also making
decisions about food based on their
texture like delicious foods like that
have weird it's just like wait six
months you couldn't taste your smell not
a single thing no it was like four
months but then after that it lost the
taste but smell like coffee smelled bad
like my favorite thing in the world made
me like nauseous a lot of really
familiar smells made me like sick does
it smell good now normal but they
smelled like putrid and fetched it yeah
wouldn't you be able to get in the best
shape of your life and that's in that's
six months
like you could you could just eat kale
you could just eat kale for like you
know the whole six months and not care
did you do it
sorry comedians are like high performers
now you all look like [ __ ] popeyes no
i [ __ ] the whole point of being a
comedian is you don't have to do ice
baths and saunas at the hospital the
thing is with me is it's just like it
even actually happened i was saying i
went to the beach with neighbors of mine
and i i was at the beach you know
whatever and you know took shirt off in
the in the water with the with the kids
and my neighbor was like i just you know
i don't mean to be a dicky because i
just thought you were in like better
shape and i was like oh jesus i was like
yeah i had coveted you know he was like
yeah yeah yeah
he was like he gives you tits
but he said that yeah
i thought you were like ripped but like
i'm not even scared that my wife's
around you shirtless it's like yeah it's
good yeah yeah so somebody noticed if
you weren't wearing a thick boy bike
club tank top no i know i read because
that's the thing i'd rather i'd rather
be all the way fat or all the way jacked
because this in between it's like it's a
letdown for people it's in between
because people think you're not
achieving your goal right so they're
like
so close yeah they're like yeah you know
what i mean to be like cut if for as a
man is really i know jasmine is always
like that's not what women want she's
like i don't want that at all at all if
you really start getting shredded we're
just like oh you're gonna cheat you're
cheating yeah or you're gay or whatever
yeah it's just or like you know it to me
it's it's i just go for every ab is
one lesson
that you've read
jasmine's like you know what's hot if
when you throw the kids in the pool and
and you throw them up she's like oh that
that's like what i want to see like just
like a strong father with his kids
that's how i don't care that you have
tits yeah you have to be useful yeah
yeah she's like you should be strong but
you don't have to be cut yeah pay for
[ __ ] that's embarrassing it's
embarrassing
yeah yeah she's probably cheating right
there but what about it what about the
reverse what about a couple
chemistry with contractors only because
i know how horrible all of them are yeah
yeah oh the contract got easier
because she walks at him with his
[ __ ] tool belt he's like what's up
you want some [ __ ] yeah yeah
i think a ripped woman i like a ripped
woman i like a manly woman actually what
does that mean like a woman with big
hands i like um i like a woman i don't
like like a delicate dainty little woman
i like a woman that i'm like this
woman's like like manly i like a more
androgynous woman is what i'll say
is that you're like a woman who could do
who has a little
she's like uh she could take care of
herself
yeah like when somebody's very girly i'm
like
you see girls have like ripped abs that
are squares
it's a little it's a little
well i don't mind it i think women it's
a little soft i think they should be
cozy oh yeah you know what i'm saying i
fish firm but cozy like this woman is
too is too jacked for you guys
yeah that's yeah i mean that's that's a
lot you're committing there and
not i mean i don't know if that's a lot
no that is
transphobic it's a hot take from a male
comedian here you go
i know yeah yeah wait is that that's
fake that scroll to the left that's fake
yeah okay that's fake
is it
the one on the
what i say it's not left much the
product it's more like i see what went
into this like you're just only i'm not
saying but this is this is this is a
lifestyle dress i just mean like the
equivalent of a very in-shape guy like
the reverse if a girl is very like very
in shape very cut up do you feel the
same way do you feel like oh this is not
going to end well
because oh for me like do i get
intimidated for women's in really good
shape
no not no
oh look it's um if gallagher were a
bodybuilder oh there you go
yeah
yeah oh okay that's that is the wrong
color to be coming from yeah
that's a bummer
yeah she's
see that's i but i think she's like she
i'm attracted to her yeah that was for
sure
of course but it's there's a difference
between like
i'm attracted to her and like i would
want to have sex with that like
consistently forever oh yes you're
attracted to kind of everyone in a way
well she to me because she looks simply
because she looks latina i'm in yeah
there you go that's what it is yeah i i
just i don't i don't know i think women
should have a little cushion okay
yeah i think i think i'll say that my
like hold on i'm just saying the body
the feet that make it so that body can
happen
are gross okay the callous is needed
that's a good point yeah for that body
to exist yeah there's no way she's gonna
be her skin's gonna be soft and yeah
it's
yeah all bets are off what if
everything's great feet are
a crime
body builder feet are [ __ ] gnarly
yeah would it be
like a
crime everything else is great but just
like you recoil at them can you can you
handle it just keep socks my
i'm going to say no only because my feet
truly look broken i was kind of fine
that's okay it looks like you're yeah it
looks like you
killed the threat
yeah like it looked like you handled
something i just don't think you want to
get uh cte from her thighs when you're
eating her out i would say the only
thing the only thing
the only time that i was ever truthfully
turned off by like a pretty girl that i
was dating was a girl i was dating once
had like like insanely bad breath that
was i just called those words you know
what a lot of uh if there's a theory
about that like halitosis like really if
it's really bad that you might be
related uh like in some remote
you know what's so funny you say that
you know what's so funny you say that
because like there was a girl
that my friend dated and he would talk
about all the time that like she didn't
like really smell good down there even
though she was clean like there was
something going on like he was like
there's a problem it's a problem and
then one of our other friends started
dating her and had known all this and
says i don't smell that at all and we
always thought like do you like when you
connect with like my other friends dick
that's yeah but like pheromones is a
real thing i think the one that you
connect with you don't smell and see the
thing that the guy who did or girl who
didn't connect with smells and see i
believe that that's so wow like
evolution punishes incest really make
you not
that's actually why joe coyne and
chelsea handler broke up because they
found out they were related
that's what it was they thought
he was like his breath sounds like [ __ ]
who smelled who smelled the other one
chelsea said joe coy's red smell like
[ __ ] and it's like i realized that it
was my third cousin
chelsea was like i forgot i [ __ ]
junior seau 20 years ago
this has been
how many minutes are we at
where was that
i don't know what podcast i was
listening to or something was like yeah
network shows are more for comedians to
go on to like stunt and like like mess
around and just have stories of down
their podcasts like the stefano went on
and bombed on when he went yeah
that's not what that
like that's so funny to me that that's
like a well i no what happened was is
you know whitney hosted the wendy
williams show oh yeah you were on it
went on and i i like took some big
swings yeah and hit some big misses yeah
and so i was like listen
by the way it was 11 a.m yeah but
whitney was laughing at them and whitney
had some good jokes too she had like
sperm jokes and it was like the audience
was just not ready in daytime that it's
a bunch of like meth zombies that are
just there for the free 50 bucks you
know what i mean like you're doing
comments so what i did was though after
that i was like you know what the
narrative i'm going to go with here is
i'm going to say i meant to do this to
talk about it on podcasting and then
that kind of worked for the podcast
fence was like well now i'm just going
to make this a thing right one of the
nick cannon show and bomb
that one
canceled two weeks later
i did the lilly singh show canceled the
day i did it yeah you did it oh really
oh no [ __ ] really yeah yeah i remember
and then i remember michelle buteaux
texting me that night she was like it's
okay sweetie blah blah blah i was like
michelle it's it's a bit i don't give a
[ __ ]
it was very much like is comedians like
we are so aware of what something
deserves and how quickly we should laugh
and it was all these you know sort of
like you know whatever fentanyl zombies
in the audience and you uh like as soon
as it was something like uh baby blood
right right oh i'm bombing
well i remember the guy the guy who was
like i don't know if he was like the
stylist or like the guy helping me in
like my dress room like this you know
fun gay guy like he was talking before
the show hard it was to book a white guy
on that [ __ ] and then
yeah and then he was like i remember it
was like you know like this guy like you
know he's like oh yeah baby like you
know talking having fun he's like oh
yeah yeah where's your accent from like
that like you know having fun
and we're having so much fun when i
bombed walking off stage
he didn't even look at me he was like
this
and then you know they have cars you
know like a car service nobody helped me
go to my car after the agreement i had
to find my car on 56th street whatever i
was like am i you yeah the nick cannon
was even it was another bad one and they
came in the
mike the situation did better than me on
the nick harris show he killed harder
than me
because i was taking big [ __ ] swings
which is so funny because if you weren't
a real comic you would have thought you
killed you know what i mean like just
the idea that he was like and the pizza
parlor where they were pedophiles and
molested kicks oh why yeah yeah
yeah it's like a lady in a wheelchair
not laughing
i'm like i'm gonna tip you over like i'm
at a comedy
and club michelle was just like yeah
well it was yeah yeah no then you
started going in on them you're like
there's no jokes here yeah yeah you're
like they're just talking and you're
yeah i was like you guys are just making
political points getting by we're just
showing that we're like have self-esteem
i like my body the way it is yeah yeah
yeah and then it was like i was like
rolling my eyes like i i was like that
guy like i didn't understand the
situation i was in you know
and epstein didn't kill himself
i was like chappelle is trans and they
were like
christmas gifts for the family would be
yeah
it was like a holiday episode yeah it's
all dates it's daytime all the
time can't i will say though wendy
williams dude if you go back and like
she's wild she's cool as [ __ ] too
like she's nuts like i feel like when
you look back and you look at like okay
like podcasters like you guys maybe like
did we look up that like howard stern
and yeah whoever you know that kind of
anthony yeah exactly like when you watch
like old wendy williams stuff she's
still on network television just like
you guys i think t.i is gay
[Laughter]
because she just out she on air just
said something
really i don't repeat it because that
was the whole thing but she just
really really intimate stuff about
method man's wife that nobody knew or
something like that she talked about he
was like what are you what are you
[ __ ] doing
t.i is gay
dude it's wild dude she's out of her
mind it's in the best way 14 extremely
messed up moments
you're number one
have you ever heard the video but she
used to always talk about whitney
houston say she was gay and then she got
finally got on the phone with whitney
houston and woody who's been hung up on
her because she was all right are you on
crack right now how much cracking no
wait wait go down to this so she's still
on the show wait look look what wait
omarosa look at the video where i'm
arose when she said terry crews wasn't
brave for coming forward about this i
was asked by meetings
it was brave of him to come out i said
no it's not brave he's just talking oh
my god have you seen the video of
where
oh my god
she said the victims of michael
jackson's sexual abuse were lying and
going after money williams was the
original tim
yes
have you seen the video of the tick tock
star who died she's like this tick stock
star just got murdered he has 2.8
million followers i've never heard of
him
[Laughter]
she's such a [ __ ] savage
i love her when she made anti-trans
comments while talking about caitlyn
jenner if i was chris i would be
eternally angry at this entire situation
i'm sorry i would be and i'd be even
more angry that caitlyn is so beautiful
because a lot of men try to transition
and some of all some of y'all no points
is bonkers there was probably one on
that list oh there you go
let's see if you can get that's me on
the wendy williams
i'm just getting crushed
here it is
[Applause]
this is the whole interview though
[Applause]
i'm glad you're here
[Applause]
oh no i know how to chill but i will not
be disrespected
okay
this is not the time for you to look for
your moment i invited you here
[Applause]
oh my god dude you should win an enemy
for your
appearance no kenny has the camera right
here this is the up-close camera would
you like it to be seen
the book comes out in october
what did i just do oh my god
i don't have him now where he is
listen
we're gonna start this over please help
me welcome my guest omarosa
[Applause]
[Music]
so
from the clip which i was one of the
reasons excuse me you were the reason
that i watched celebrity apprentice and
the reason being is that you are a
person who did wendy williams
was that a professional movement
clearly trump sees something like that
from you which is why he invites you
back over and over i understand that
there could possibly be a show that you
all will be working on together possibly
but i did the celebrity apprentice
because it was about charity and i work
with kids in compton who don't have an
opportunity to have a voice to fight for
themselves they face crime they face
violence and they don't have people to
look up to so i went on that show to
tell people about positive vibrations my
charity in compton california okay well
that was that wow it's weird they like
kind of are doing a good job yeah
because you think you know that's
bubbling under the surface right now did
she flip out at some point wendy
williams no but have you seen when she
passed out on the show
who did you ever seen one doing this can
you win himself
for a liberty
this is wild
nuts dude this is what is whitney
williams why is she who is what is she
williams was a broadcaster a giant dj in
new york oh yeah oh the one with the
figure
but of course
this is her on her show like just but
she was just a dj that's what she was
and she was she was like um
celebrity
correspondent yeah yeah i'm allowed to
say that but she was she's that big
right
costume contest we do it every year so
it was a lot of fun let's get started
our first caress
now
you never saw that before
and then she comes back dude can i tell
you something every wendy williams rerun
is wild like it is truly still the most
compelling show she's okay so we can
laugh right yeah yeah because that's
insane
she dropped like i almost just passed
out on my own like one of those balloon
men outside of car dealership
that whole entire dance she did was
insane
it looks fake
no one was more entertaining than her
when she was trying and when she can you
go back to that
what what should happen what happened
she had like a blood you know whatever
later is
um like i dodged a bullet with her um
because
uh uh sorry i just went like not because
i was supposed to work with alec baldwin
um
i did have a show with him a couple
years ago i was like dodged a bullet
oops
but uh no she uh sherry shepherd was
also a guest host she was the week
before me and the week after me and
someone was like oh should sherry
shepherd like replace you if you don't
come back and she goes i don't know i
would not watch her
host my show
like i didn't watch any of the episodes
yeah like she was like throwing shade at
the people guest hosting conversation
like michael rappaport then host a week
like random [ __ ] random people
are a similar yeah
you know
the [ __ ] she just throws out is so great
like also i wasn't allowed to say when i
was on the show because when she would
talk about the britney spears thing she
would go like death to them all death to
all of them that was her quote about
like all the conservators that were like
holding britney spears captain oh sure
she would like call to like if you see
them in public like kill them like she's
just like [ __ ]
she's fearless in a way that like no one
on television is shout out wendy
williams shout out to andy williams
you're watching and we know that you are
she i gotta say though imagine you're in
the audience and she goes into that into
that thing like because the look of
horror she had to look she wasn't like
confused or like i'm gonna pass out she
had a look of horror in her eyes and it
almost looks great and then she just
drops straight down yeah seemed like she
got it got control of it yeah and then
but but
it looks it looks like an snl sketch it
looks like an snl sketch
i swear to god i can't she caught this
then i think about what happened i think
she no no no no no look if you're in the
i think she comes on after the
commercial breakdown is like
legitimately fine the fact that she's
dressed
is an extra
unbelievable picture of the statue of
liberty collapsing too
it's funny she's just overheated in her
car she drops straight down
and i'm back i love that when she fell
they probably went right to like a my
pillow commercial
first of all that is
so scary and they they just shoved her
back out into the commercial right away
and chalked it up to it was just from
the heat from the outfit like how do
they know she didn't get a cat scan
funny she came in with like this statue
of liberty crown tilted
they're like this usually happens right
before the show yeah yeah it's insane
that she drops straight down instead of
forward you've got to watch some of her
monologues she will come out and she'll
have tea in a cup and and she won't say
anything for like a couple minutes
she'll just be like
no yeah it's incredible
is she groundbreaking is it like
groundbreaking yeah she is fearless in a
way that
very few people and i can't take your
eyes off all right because how's the
network gonna let her just sip a cup of
tea and not speak on on live there
i mean literally it's whatever amber was
saying about she defamation every
episode she's like oh that guy's gay
well he's killing me like
and that's probably why kind of similar
to trump but you didn't really hear
about it so much because he ju you
couldn't by the time you were trying to
nail wendy on this one she already was
doing another one
yeah yeah you couldn't she would she and
she just she's like petty yeah in a way
that's like so unnecessary yeah she'll
be like christina aguilera a great new
song the face was a little anyway you're
just like jesus yeah yeah
burning bridges like all about the uh
the listener and the viewer i'm not
trying to make friends with celebrities
i'm not trying to keep friends like i am
here
because i feel like you don't meet like
the celebrities probably don't like her
but you don't meet like any average
person that doesn't love wendy everybody
loves williams because she hated
celebrities before any of us caught on
like
she never respected celebrities she's
she worked sick amount of money i would
imagine that she understands
her own show i would imagine this
running daytime syndicated i think it's
so she's got like she's she's like
hundreds charlemagne started out as like
her like assistant on the show like 25
years ago i think that they're they're
not they don't get along
i don't know something i don't know
10 million per year okay well that's and
then she was married to some guy who
probably i mean who knows what happened
55k and up not bad
yeah and then she's got the jewelry and
kfc qvc [ __ ] like that um but sorry her
books are incredible and her advice she
does these advice things at the end yeah
where she'll ask someone from the
audience like what's your and they'll be
like hi um how you doing they do the
thing
yeah and it's all these white people
being like how are you doing and she's
like you do it she doesn't give a [ __ ]
appropriate we don't care
i don't care and uh people will be like
so anyway i'm here with my husband and
we haven't had sex and
you know like a couple years and we're
trying to figure out she's like leave
them [ __ ] that guy she's like you can
get anything you want divorce that guy
like she's she does does she do podcasts
i don't think she's ever done a podcast
she said something i think recently
because now she's on the bench a little
she had some health problems and she
said like i'll do podcasts if i make
what joe rogan made or something yeah i
was on i did open it i mean well she was
a guest on house i did a guest with i
would she was the guest one day when i
was in on openings
she was just [ __ ] she was just [ __ ]
around with jim norton for an hour
just [ __ ] around with him saying he's
telling the scene who's gay and all that
and yeah it was a funny episode she is
good television yeah every second is
entertaining you never know what she's
going to say
all right i might have to throw that on
my tivo
why not
she is like to me she is like a master
class in just being entertaining even if
you're not saying but her show is it an
interview show or is it what is the show
about the talk show like like she'll
have a guess
like old oprah like that yeah like a
topic with panelists yeah okay like the
view and stuff i don't know she doesn't
that was only for the guest hosting
so what was her show like it was just
her talking to camera she would just be
like okay so usher
and everyone goes ooh because they know
she hate you know i mean so usher's in
argentina this week and she's dipping a
tea bag yeah
when you got to know what i'm saying a
lot of gay men down there
and he went to atlanta last week
yeah
was there even like show prep or she was
just like i'm gonna come out start
talking yeah that's what i was gonna ask
you like when you're hanging out okay
okay okay pull up uh wendy williams
making pizza
um the guy from a brooklyn pizzeria from
lucas i know this entire thing by heart
uh wendy williams making pizza wendy
williams pizza just do pizza it what's a
place in new york that's a really great
pizza place uh lucas
uh ellen beast permanente gardens
um
uh patsy's patties
uh julianas giuliani rimaldi's uh uh
yeah yeah
grimaldi's patsies
potties
bloom cafe
[Music]
she dated biggie
what says wendy williams back in the day
before her surgery when she dated biggie
tony bologna's pizza on his pizza oh
yeah that place is [ __ ] sick
[Laughter]
she goes are you single like she's you
know just in this clip she's very all
over the way she's like are you single
and he's like
say it he go um he goes i am i told you
i am
i hate men
what what is that even about i don't
know she's just crazy she's just like
it's just you never know what she's
gonna say but also he responded
why did she hate me probably you have to
see the first six minutes okay it's so
mad it's just mad it's crazy though how
how the audience like that awkward
moment lived out in front of an audience
like they don't even like there's no i
guess she just didn't give a [ __ ] like
at all genius she's not trying to do
what anyone else she'll never come back
i don't know she's does anybody have any
idea what the health concern is or it's
so underrated no it's
something with her circulation of her
legs i can find out and she just can't
stand or something can you give us just
an update on her legs please yeah what's
going on like does she need compression
socks my dad has something to keep him
elevated my dad by the way didn't [ __ ]
for 15 days i told you that she has
graves disease
we go back we
read that oh when do you
click on that so here's the other thing
she didn't wash her boob for two weeks
after hallie okay
she also shared that uh she has
lymphedema a buildup of fluid in the
body due to lymphatic system being
damaged or blocked so graves disease and
that lymphedema sucks yes i bet she
probably doesn't want to come out in
public because she probably looks like
when you get lymphedema like that you
look like a swole like you look like um
like like it's like this like it's crazy
you get so swollen with like ice i think
well no you're in the bed with literally
a compression device on both legs i
don't know where lymphedema is where
it's like literally like you look you
might you might gain a hundred pounds
with lymphedema
that's fluid like i bet your face is
like this and lymphatic drainage is not
something that obviously no lymphedema
is like a it's like a um like a it's
like a circulatory issue it's it's like
systemic look at you you sound like a
medical person i'm american i'm with
school for medical personnel
whitney cummings where you gonna be next
uh i'm going to be
uh in my house because special's coming
out and i'm not going to tour again into
the fall netflix right netflix yes sir
how nice is that
it's
it's super nice except for now
it's like oh you're not just gonna do
yourself on youtube [ __ ] sell out i'm
like okay i
like youtube is not right it's psyched
for a woman talking for an hour yet um
so yeah netflix is still i think the
place for for me to do it all right you
know netflix what's it called jokes
jokes just jokes no kicks no secret ted
talks
coming out is gay at the end there you
go
turn it on it's not an episode of
stranger things it's whitney cummings
special strangest thing that's it
whitney comings love you babe thanks for
having me love you bye babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate